there's nobody else to blame everything
is your fault the good stuff in your
life that's on you you either put
yourself in a position to deserve it to
be around people that want to help to
take care of you luck came by you were
able to capitalize on it but will you
have the fair to get on and maybe that's
it maybe you just got really lucky but
you had the fair to get on the bus and
that's on you so you should be very
proud of the things that you have in
your life but all the things in your
life that aren't your satisfaction those
are all your fault now I'm gonna tell
you a story my wife who happens to be
British let's say that she is with her
mom and she's in the bedroom that she
grew up in she's all safe and sound
doors locked the alarm is on her mom's
in the Next Room making sure that she's
safe but right then a meteorite comes
screaming through the atmosphere crashes
into her bedroom and kills her whose
fault is that now if people don't know
me everybody goes to is dumb luck Divine
Providence it's nobody's fault how could
you blame aim yourself well let me tell
you how I could blame myself and when
you hear the reality of this and you
realize that I am in no way shape or
form being hyperbolic it actually is my
fault hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because of my first
business I struggled to stay afloat I
quit my business partner and the thing
that kept me going was studying the
stories of famous entrepreneurs and
seeing how they struggled and seeing
what they had to overcome and listen to
their wisdom motivation gave me the
Courage the strength the belief to go
one more day and see my business through
and in all honesty I still need the
inspiration wisdom motivation today for
my business too so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how you can
focus your mind enjoy
I know right now there is an
organization that tracked what are
called near-earth objects in fact I'm on
the board of the X prize
one of the prizes that they're trying to
raise money for is for this problem to
track all these known objects and to
find some way lasers planted nuclear
explosions something
to make sure that if something is ever
on a collision course for Earth that we
can stop it
literally four weekends ago
I had a chance to vote for this to say
this should be a prize
and I didn't
so now not only have I never sent a dime
of my money to help I've never sent an
email with encouraging words I've never
called them up to tell them what I think
they should do now I literally voted
against them
so if a meteorite happens to kill my
wife
I don't have anyone to blame but myself
that's so apparently true
now I think it's the right decision I
think that putting the time and energy
into something that has such a
vanishingly slim possibility of actually
happening makes no sense you have to
know where to put your energies all of
us have a finite amount of energy so you
at some point have to triage and decide
what are the things that I'm going to
attack I'm far more worried about my
wife getting into a car
the likelihood of her dying is almost
certainly going to be
at this point
something to do with heart disease or
something to do with an aneurysm things
like that
it most certainly isn't going to be a
meteorite crashing through the roof and
killing her but if it did
I wouldn't waste time blaming anyone
else
now the key here
the key
I wouldn't beat myself up over it
I would be crestfallen my wife is my
everything it would be a loss so
devastating I don't even want to
comprehend it
but I just wouldn't waste time blaming
anyone else because the reality is
and let this come home
your life
is the exact reflection of the choices
you have made
love your life great you've made awesome
choices
hate your life
I'm sorry
you've made bad choices
but the good news is you're in control
and that's why literally the first time
I wrote this whole article it was my
first blog article and it was all about
how if I were hit by a drunk driver I
would take ownership of that I would say
that is my fault and people were pissed
and I was so shocked I literally thought
I want to pull people from The Matrix
what's the one gift that I could give
people that will change their life
forever
and I wrote this whole thing and I was
like talking about like oh man you're in
this spot and it ends up being a kill
box and there's cars on either side of
you and a car in front of you and your
horn dies and you can't even start your
car and move you look in the rearview
mirror and this drunk driver's plowing
down they Smash Into You
and it's all your fault
and thank God
because now you remember that you're in
control
but people thought I was victim shaming
people were outraged that I would say
that that was anyone's fault but the
drunk driver
but I don't want to do that
because I choose not to ever be a victim
I cannot choose whether I'm victimized
but I have the ability to say I will
never
be a victim
because there's always something you can
do differently
there is always something you can do
differently
and once you understand that you can
always make a different choice and get a
different reaction and that's the power
in your life that's the power that you
have is no matter what's going on you
can choose to think differently believe
differently see differently
all of those things are a choice read
Man's Search for meaning by Victor
Frankel lost this whole family to the
Holocaust was in I think five different
concentration camps
and he said the thing that people die of
in a concentration camp is the loss of a
why
and Nietzsche said if you have a why you
can survive almost any how
because you can always change how you
think about something
and when you change how you think about
it's what we've been talking about all
day when you change how you think about
it you actually change the event rule
number two is embrace the suffering with
David Goggins you have to tap into
suffering every day of your life because
we have so much scarring that we have to
clean up you have to look at suffering
as almost like I look at failure foreign
to succeed you must fail
[Music]
in failure and in suffering all the
answers are in there all the answers to
all the test questions the test is your
life
all the answers are in there you have to
live in suffering and pain and failure
all the time you have to learn I need to
visit it like people hate working out
you're only going to visit working out
maybe an hour a day 23 other hours of
the day you're not in it
but how you become in shape is you must
visit suffering visit working out one
hour a day visit suffering one hour a
day visit your past failures one hour a
day the relationship with it is the
answers are in there
they they are in there within the
suffering go in there and I call it the
live autopsy the live autopsy how you
find out someone died they crack you
open after you're dead
how you can live is do it while you're
alive
go back in your brain crack it open
while you're alive don't wait until
you're dead to figure out why you died
do it while you are living go in there
go into the suffering go into the pain
of your life and say why did this suck
for me so bad
why am I afraid of all this stuff why
have I shut down the whole world
I guarantee I tell you why you shut down
the whole world it is in these Nooks of
the suffering within your brain in the
scarring
are all the answers to why you are on
the couch feeling sorry for yourself
they lie within the scars
visit them for at least an hour a day
study them
and then you'll find out more about
yourself you will then grow
so don't look at us every day I suffer
go into it an hour a day learn from
yourself learn from Life learn from your
failures learn from your insecurities
learn from your self-doubt don't just
say I'm afraid to jump off an airplane
thank you
what makes you afraid of it study it
that's why I studied my mind why I
became so powerful in the mind because I
realized I was weak
so instead of running away from the mind
I dove into and say what is making me
weak oh this makes sense I Came From
Hell
I came from a place that beat me down to
nothing which is why I'm afraid
all this makes sense so systematically
one by one I went back and met every
single person in my mind every situation
I went one-on-one with them again in my
mind and said okay
let's now revisit this and that's how
you do it that's how it works rule
number three is max out your life with
Ed mylett there's invisible progress in
life I got two things for you to finish
I have a chapter in the book about
compound pounding you listen to me on
this everybody around the world you're
making more progress and you're closer
to your dream than you think I think I
said that in the beginning I went to a
party for a bunch of five-year-olds
and they got this pinata and the first
kid gets up and hits the pinata whack
quack quack no candy comes out of the
pinata
he kind of quits and goes away it's kind
of like an entrepreneur they get the
next kid blindfold him spin his little
butt around he's you know like that's
how we all are in this no idea then we
direct him he's hitting the pinata no
candy comes out
third kid hits the heck out of it what
these kids didn't know is they were
compound pounded it didn't show but they
were breaking that pinata down invisibly
you all with me on that say yes the last
kid the kid no one wanted to pick the
scrawny kid the nerdy kid the one no one
was talking to he gets the bat last and
he walks up with the weakest swing he
ever seen hits it once Boop all the
candy comes out and everybody celebrates
because everyone else is making the
invisible progress was it the last hit
that broke it open or the cumulative
hits which was it the cumulative hits
most people in life quit before the
candy comes out they quit before the
candy comes out of their business their
body their relationships not knowing
they're much closer to the dream than
they think they are but the progress is
invisible you got to keep hitting that
pinata in your life keep taking swings
one more swing one more swing one more
swing knowing you're making invisible
progress why here's why my dad's in
heaven
and let me tell you I know he's in
heaven
because I'm going right behind him
and I have this philosophy you've heard
me say this before somebody but I want
you to hear this differently today based
on the one more differently today
because you're gonna be faced where
you're my dad someday
see I think when you go to heaven I want
the Lord to go hey well done good and
faithful servant but I know some he's
going to introduce me to the man he made
me to be
he's going to introduce you to the woman
you were capable of becoming remember
when I said you're neglecting your kids
when you're not chasing your dreams and
your potential
you're actually neglecting you
you're neglecting your spirit you're
neglecting your soul you're neglecting
the very reason you were born nothing
makes me more proud than to see someone
chasing their potential chasing that
happiness chasing that Bliss I don't
care if the candies come out yet
I care that you swing see I want to meet
this dude I was born to be I'm gonna say
man I've been chasing you all my life
every decision I made I messed a lot of
them up but I get back on track I'm
trying to catch you and I want him to go
you did it man you caught me you had all
the memories all the moments all the
contribution all the difference all the
stuff man you did it you maxed out your
life to me
that's heaven
I did it I could tell you that man's
hand I was holding at the end there he
did it
and he didn't do it the first 35 years
he didn't do it at all and then he
started chasing that man
and he caught him
he helped so many people quiet simple
man he just loved people who used his
faults his frailties his mistakes his
sins
his weaknesses his fears
to help other people
hell
you meet her
you meet him
hey man I don't I don't recognize you
total strangers
you didn't do it
we didn't have the moments you didn't
have the memories you didn't help the
people you didn't feel it
you neglected your family
you neglected yourself
I don't want that for you I want you to
rise up and go to Heaven someday you all
with me on that also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet design specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is put in the
work with Eric Thomas let me tell you
something you could dream all you want
kid candy me the other day he bought 24
years old he wants to be an animator
everybody dogging him out he was like
E.T maybe my dreams are too big I said
no such thing ain't nothing wrong with
your dreams
your strategy is off though
your dreams are great keep your Big
Dreams the people who dog you out is
probably people with small dreams don't
worry about them you're gonna run across
a lot of them you're gonna run across a
lot of average people who don't think
big don't let that disturb you don't let
that distract you you keep your goals
but I need to know the steps what steps
are you going to take to make that
happen what you gonna do on Monday I
don't see that what you gonna do on
Tuesday like you just showing me your
dream I don't see what you doing on
Wednesday what time you getting up on
Saturday
what you doing on the weekend when
everybody else chilling
show me your plan don't just show me
your dreams
so if we gonna fit win 58 we're gonna
have to have some steps to go with that
all doable I walked in here bro some of
y'all too tall to walk in the door
you got what it you got you got the
athleticism now we need to plan
you got to be intentional and deliver it
I don't wear Reebok ain't nothing wrong
with Reebok I just don't wear them I
didn't associate I don't know nobody
other than the pumps you know what I'm
saying to the duck I don't really know a
lot of people that work I know Nike I
wear Muhammad Ali for a reason I wear
jeans for a reason I ain't trying to be
fashionable Muhammad Ali was the best to
do it and I saw him as a kid I was born
in the 70s I saw him go to work I
watched MJ do his thing I don't wear it
because I'm fashionable I wear it
because I want to be Associated I want
to be around greatness I know what Nike
represents Serena with him Kobe was with
him Jordan was with him you got to be
intentional and deliberate
stop now here's what I mean when I say
120. so I had a guy the other day you
know I was on the phone with a guy and
he said he was a Laker fan from back in
the day I was like oh wait what air he
was like you know Kobe console I was
like all right do me a favor you really
a Laker fan he's like yeah I was like
name everybody that played on the squad
that year
couldn't name him I said bro I thought
you said you was a Laker fan
I'm a piston
I can't name him I can name Isaiah do
Mars I can name them all John Sally I
can name him Rodman I can name it
lambeer I could name him Buddha
microwave
I can name them name them he could name
them I said who can you name he said I
can name Kobe Gasol and um Odom I was
like who was the best out of all of them
they said Kobe I said absolutely 120.
the reason why you can't name the other
Jokers not because they didn't play on
the team and not because they weren't
professional but they weren't giving
120. so you don't remember who they were
and you went to a whole bunch of the
games
they were professional but they weren't
120 you'll never forget Kobe he was 120.
not perfect but 120. he gave everything
he had Mike was 120 gave everything he
had 120. Michael Phelps 120 Serena 120.
I'm saying to you that since you have to
give an effort anyway it might as well
be 120 why because when you do 120 you
ain't never got to work again you can
name some dudes in the league that won
120 they got jobs now
Kobe you've never had to work again Mike
never had to work again why because they
would die Serena will never work again
Michael Phelps will never work again he
didn't just swim he he was a swimmer
swimmer Serena was the best that ever do
it I'm telling you here's what I know
it's going to take to get to 58 it's
going to take your best game every night
[Music]
do you get your best game I don't have
the slightest idea I get my best game by
getting up at three o'clock in the
morning people say to me all the time
you get up at three o'clock in the
morning if you lost your mind I say have
you lost yours I live in America you
mean to tell me I can get up at three
o'clock in the morning and be a
multi-millionaire you mean to tell me I
can get up at three o'clock in the
morning I'm gonna get a master's in a
PhD I could be a New York Times
bestseller you mean to tell me you mean
to tell me I can take care of my family
about getting up at three o'clock in the
morning and I can take a nap whenever I
want to
I'll do whatever it takes I've been
getting up at three o'clocks in the
morning since about 19 20. first hour I
dedicate to God next hour my collability
crew next hour a little walking I'll try
to do too much exercise you feel me I'll
be seeing people I'm like you're about
to die you know what I'm saying you're
doing too much I'm just gonna walk you
know what I'm saying because I see the
old ladies just walking in the mall hey
oh hey I'll see them lifting their
weights and doing your burpees and that
like that they just walking for an hour
I was like that's what I like that
that's what I'm gonna do so I'm just
being real if you live in a third world
country I don't care what time you get
up I don't care what time you go to bed
you're in a third world country you
there you can't you can't be an NBA star
you can't be an NFL star you guys have
an opportunity of a lifetime and it's a
short window
I'm telling you just a short window
you're not going to be doing this at 47
years old 58 years old 62. so if you got
10 years why not give 120 because if you
give 120
. I feel good bro I get 120 I'm walking
through the I'm talking about airport
I'm going out to eat cats like I love it
too because you know I grew up in the
African-American community so you know
brothers be coming up to me like what up
E.T like bro I don't be taking pictures
with grown men but
[Music]
you changed my life bro you got me
ironing my wife's clothes
foreign
get through chemotherapy bruh it feel
good given 120 and know when I die that
my name will live forever my videos will
live forever it feels good knowing that
I own my own Dynasty and I run my own
life because I gave 120 and was it
difficult absolutely it was did I want
to chill out while other people was on
the plane playing video games and
watching movies I wanted to watch it too
but I was working on my dissertation it
was worth it
that dissertation was worth it the
Masters was working before the GED was
worth it they're writing the book
I'm asking you to do me a favor I'm
asking you if you're gonna get the 58
you can't give me 70 30. you can't give
me 60 40. you can't give me 75.25 you
can't give me 80 20. you're going
against some other dudes in this league
who have won and they tasted success and
they
they don't want to give it up
they tasted it y'all
they felt what it felt like to be on the
bus I know what it's like to be on the
bus I know what it feels like guys there
are people who live that lifestyle and
they not trying to give it up
you got to take it from them
ain't nobody trying to give it up kids
come here all the time E.T I'm gonna
take your spot ah
I want you to take it but I might I'm
not giving it to you I want you to be
the next great speaker I do we did if
you had a hundred of me in the school
system a hundred of me in the prisons it
wouldn't be enough for all to cry and
what our kids are going through it
wouldn't be enough but I'm not about to
give it to you you're about to come take
it rule number five is face your fears
with Selena Gomez you just said that
that everyone goes through a rock bottom
moment like everyone goes through that
in their life in different ways how have
you become more mindful of your fears
and rock bottoms because I think often
we ask people like would I look at your
life and I think you've gone through so
many difficult things and
you know how do you deal with fears now
because we all still have fears we all
still have worries but I feel like
you've found a way to become mindful of
those things and become a bit more
prepared for them well thank you I I
think maybe you are seeing a good side
of me because I have the hardest time
doing it I don't know my fears are
relatively you know they're quieter
maybe I should say you know like for
example this documentary coming out I am
still nervous I'm nervous for the
reaction
um even though I know that I have good
intentions behind it
I think that I just have to understand
that my fears are only going to continue
to
show me what I'm capable of the more
that I faced my fears the more that I
feel I'm gaining strength I'm gaining
wisdom and I just want to keep doing
that and I just hope to get better hope
to get smarter I hope to become stronger
and be a great person rule number six is
build radical confidence with Lisa billu
what was one of the first things that
you started to do or experiment with
where you started to gain confidence or
build confidence so I'll love that you
said build so I've got a line in the
book it's like it's like a muscle you
won't go to the gym and want glutes of
Steal after doing a couple of squats I
mean I do want that to happen
but do you get gluta still choose your
glutes I have no idea definitely no I
don't have any glutes so I have no idea
it's amazing but you don't just go what
you want to but you don't and so that is
like with confidence we kind of want it
already but yeah if you think of it like
a muscle you can go and you can train it
and that's the point is that for me it
became being thrown into the deep end
not feeling like I had any confidence I
was completely insecure I was actually
very inadequate so it wasn't even like
oh I just you know I had it and I was
just you know not feeling great about
myself no no when we started Quest I
didn't know what I was doing at all and
so the confidence part came afterwards
it came as the byproduct of doing things
freaking out falling on the floor
getting back up learning from it and
then over time becoming competent and
the confidence part I think I think it's
just we want to feel great about
ourselves that's it we want to feel
great about ourselves before we try
something perspective is everything so
how do you shift that and so how I did
it was instead of focusing on the
confidence say what is that end goal I
want confidence to do what and now once
you have that then you put in a plan a
blueprint of how you're going to get
there because your confidence will come
after that I love that I I think you're
completely shifting how people think
about confidence because I still see
those things like this is how to be
confident stand this way do this and and
those things work and they're useful but
you're talking about a deeper sense of
confidence how do you define confidence
and radical confidence obviously how do
you define that because I do think
you're encouraging us all to move to a
much more deeper level of confidence
yeah I'm trying differently thank you
with the word confidence I do think is
it's about a feeling you want to feel
great about yourself before you start
something and radical confidence is it's
not about feeling great about your
yourself it's about how do I get to that
end goal so I can have the life and the
dream I've always wanted that's it and
so it's not going to be easy and that's
the big part of it and because it's not
easy and because you're all the time
moving forward even when you're scared
you're moving forward even when you're
fearful how do you keep moving forward
now it's very easy to say oh just do it
anyway when you're scared no no if
you've got crippling anxiety if you're
like really feeling badly about yourself
telling someone to just do it anyway
doesn't actually help so to me it has to
be a blueprint if you want to lose
weight some people like my mum she was
so severely overweight just telling her
well mommy I'll get you a gym membership
it wouldn't have helped because she
feels so badly about herself she doesn't
even have the radical confidence to walk
into the gym so okay how do you actually
get someone to take the health or like
take their Stepping Stones maybe right
now all you need to do is put your shoes
by the bed that's it that's what you're
going to do tomorrow you're not gonna go
to the gym you're not gonna do anything
else you're just going to put your shoes
by the bed and then the next day you're
going to put your shoes on and what
you're going to do is every time you do
it you're actually going to give
yourself a pat on the back and said
yesterday I didn't put the shoes on and
today I did and it becomes these little
microscopic movements towards the dream
that you really want so that you can
build that competence to build the
confidence yeah that I mean especially
that part the the competence to build
the confidence I completely completely
agree with you I speak to a lot of
friends who have young kids and they'd
always they'll always say to me like oh
my kid's not very confident
and or he lacks or she likes or they
lack in confidence and when I look back
to being a young kid
I would say I wasn't confident when I
was growing up and I was bullied I was
overweight I was one of the only we grew
up in the same area I was one of the
only South Asian Indian kids in our area
and so I was bullied for several things
and I would say it took me a long time
before I developed a sense of confidence
but it was exactly what you just said it
was building competence that led to
confidence so my parents forced me to go
to public speaking School built tons of
confidence my parents forced me to go to
drama school built tons of confidence so
when they forced me to build competence
that built confidence and I think we're
so scared that we don't build skills we
think we can solve how we feel without
building a skill does that make sense oh
my God 100 and that's part of it it's
like me wanting to let's say it's
getting on stage I was so petrified to
get on stage but my my goal is impact so
Tom calls me a sign he's like babe as
your husband you've said you want to
create impact but you keep saying to
these speaking gigs and so I'm just
letting you know that your actions
aren't aligned with what you say you
want in life so it's like okay typical
time typical time while they're calling
me on my stuff so he's like okay I
recognize that getting on stage actually
does solve that it serve that mission I
really am like holding my core to but
how on Earth do I get on stage how do I
build that competence when I just feel
so badly about myself when I'm so
embarrassed I'm so I'm worried about
falling on my face and like really
embarrassing myself how on Earth do I do
that and it becomes you said your
parents forced you as an adult I think
it becomes harder we get very um in our
own heads and I think you know as kids
we are easily you can learn you can walk
you can tie your shoes you learn how to
do you don't do it the first time but
you just take time but as adults we
don't give ourselves the grace to go
through that training period and so for
me in when I'm thinking about public
speaking I do think about those
incremental steps in order to get there
because I can't just want to yeah to
your point it's like I can say I really
want this
but to so many people that's just not
enough it's like it's that isn't enough
to actually get people to act on their
dream
your personality literally ad is made up
of how you think how you act and how you
feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called a mood so you say Ed what's wrong
with you I'm in a mood why are you in a
mood well this thing happened to me five
days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well well tell me the story now the
latest research on memory says that 50
percent of what we talk about in our
past isn't even the truth so we make
stuff up about the past in other words
people are reliving a life that they
didn't even have just to reaffirm that
they can't change right wow so then
what's the significance of this where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy period yes so then the
stronger the emotion that you have the
some problem or condition or person in
your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
hour away to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then teach
a person then how to trade that emotion
for an elevated emotion now trade the
emotion for an elevated emotion right so
you're going to give that up and you're
going to practice feeling gratitude for
as an example yes the person says well I
can't feel gratitude and I say
absolutely you can because you don't
practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened or it's happening to you so the
moment you open your heart and you feel
gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic where my co-worker sent me a
nasty email then I would say oh my God
God you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life and one
of the things that will help you to do
the work to create the things that you
want in your life is it will help you if
you train your mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that [ __ ]
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool date let's
go do something with this you could
create that kind of attitude every
single freaking day of your life you
could if you train your mind and if you
start taking action and training your
mind is the key piece that we're going
to talk about so for those of you that
have read the high five habit one of the
things that I talk about a lot is every
single day I find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself where you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so [ __ ] up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you're never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there well to me a
breakthrough is a moment in time it's a
moment when the impossible becomes
possible and you know just think about
it they act upon it you know it's like
you can have a concept that doesn't
create a breakthrough the breakthroughs
and you get to the point where you
actually are going to do something about
it and I ask people all the time I ask
your listeners or viewers as well it's
like I'm sure you've had a time where
you struggle with something right you're
gonna do something about this
relationship but you keep not changing
it right you know pulling back or you're
going to stop smoking or you're going to
go lose those 25 pounds or whatever it
is and you start to make progress and
then you pull back and you get
disappointed and get frustrated but then
there's some times where finally you hit
this threshold you hit this moment where
your brain says not another day not in
an hour I'm changing this relationship
I'm losing this weight I'm making this
happen and people create that
breakthrough and it can be happen it you
know it's the difference between what
triggers it versus what makes it
possible what triggers it is usually
pain or massive inspiration nothing in
between does it most people they hear
the threat threshold of pain and say
it's like you know I ask people how many
of you ever been in a relationship way
too long and everybody raises their hand
they go why why just stay you weren't
happy they weren't happy it's just
because of the unknown the uncertainties
the the idea of change it could be worse
you know to be alone but then there's
that moment when you finally hit the
threshold you go it's been painful in
the past it's painful now it's gonna be
painful future I'm gonna change it now
so the trigger that finally made that
happen I'd ask your audience if they
think it's something where they finally
broke through what was the trigger
usually that moment that day you hit a
threshold of I can't take anymore I'm
changing or
something inspired you you saw someone's
possible and they can do it I can do it
as well but that's what makes it
possible what makes it last is a change
in your emotions
or changing your belief system or a new
strategy right you and I both know
because you're both strategists the
right strategy how you can consume a
book and remember more of it in 30 or 45
minutes than you did when you used to
spend 10 days on the damn book right you
know it's the right strategy but you're
not going to find the strategy until
it's a must for you not a [ __ ] you know
what I mean or if that change in belief
it's like okay I've put up with this
crap long enough I'm better than this
there's something more in me that you
finally finding yourself or you finally
get pissed off enough or you get excited
enough to make that real change and so
what I've studied is
I like to take complex things and make
them simple because I found that you
know the more you know when I was really
young I tried to make things more
complex I think to try to convince
myself how smart I was or other people I
don't know what but it's stupid because
complexity is the enemy of execution and
the only way your life changes or your
business changes is execution so it's
like how do you make it simple and I
started looking at all these you know
I've been doing this this is my 45th
year doing this I started when I was two
of course and and I started seeing these
patterns all over the world working with
the greatest people on Earth athletes
business people the most challenged
people in prisons like what are the
common denominators and all these
cultures and they began to see there's
three things you need for a breakthrough
but most of us do them in reverse order
so we don't get the Breakthrough the
number one thing most people do when
they want to have a breakthrough they
don't they want to change their body
they want to change their Finance they
look for a strategy which makes common
sense that's what I used to do
but the problem is
strategy could be the problem and maybe
you need a better strategy but that's
not usually the real problem right like
for example three quarters of America is
overweight or obese if we're the fattest
humans in the history of the world we
all know covid other than age the number
one risk factor is obesity that's number
one and yet very few people do anything
about it and why is that is it because
you know the strategy for being fit and
strong is so complex or only the one
percent know it or it costs a fortune to
do it now you have to be fighting not to
see all the strategies to make your body
physically better around you everywhere
so it's you could have the wrong
strategy like I remember years ago on
the cover of Time Magazine they had the
Atkins diet they said you know I think
it was 15 of Americans were doing it
well if you gotta pee on a stick so you
don't get too acidic and your breath is
that bad it's pretty obvious that's not
sustainable so sometimes it's a strategy
problem but we work for the how first
and you've never figured it out
your emotions get in the way
it's the wrong sequence it's like the
dog bit Johnny Johnny bit the dog same
words different experience of your
Johnny so strategy naturally is where
people go but rarely do they change with
that what the real problem usually is
the story they've developed and a story
is just code for all the things you've
told yourself over and over again until
you believe them right there's an old
language pattern that says tell why big
enough loud enough long enough sooner or
later people believe it that was Hitler
said that and so most of us are Hitler
in our own mind so it's not that they
can't you know what do people say how
come I can't lose like I can't lose
weight because you know I've tried
everything no have you tried everything
you'd be fit right they didn't try
everything I've tried millions of things
really name them well I've tried Hunters
name them and they'll tell you three
stupid things that don't work that they
did over and over again right so it's
the story I I don't have a relationship
because all the good ones are gone or
they're gay and I'm not or I'm gay and
they're not or whatever the story is the
story is what will keep you like I'm
sure you know Jim you have so many great
strategies you share with people how do
you have times when you give someone an
answer right there in front of them and
they just can't even see it right they
don't believe it because the story is
literally blinding them in Psychology we
call it a scotoma a blind spot
but then there's one level deeper than
even the story
and that's your state the mental
emotional physical state you're in
because when you're in a low mental
emotional physical state you can have
all the brain capacity in the world but
you're not going to use it and so when
you're in a lousy State you come up with
a lousy story and then no strategy works
it doesn't matter what it is if you
don't know if you've ever noticed have
you ever gotten really angry at somebody
and then suddenly you remember all the
ways they've ever screwed you over
you've been upset with them right but on
the other hand you fall in love and
what's wrong with life nothing I have no
money it doesn't matter we're in love
it's all wonderful right so the sequence
in which we do things accelerates or
decelerates or stops progress when it
comes to a breakthrough and what I found
is change the state first you know like
when you and I can talk and give people
a million strategies but if I'm sitting
here at home in this state and I'm just
listening like this and nodding like
this yeah that makes nothing's gonna
happen so the reason that I've done
events over my lifetime and the reason
why I do immersion events you know 10 12
14 hours a day you learn a little bit at
a time like language you don't remember
the language a few years later but I
drop you in Rome and say you got no
teacher and you got 60 days I'll be
picking you up I'll pick you up 60 days
from now you're going to be speaking
Italian right especially if I put you
maybe with some passionate people who
are really going for it in their life
you're going to have a whole different
state about you you're going to develop
a new story and you're going to figure
out the strategy so I think the the
challenge for most people especially
with covet is we've all had our state
dropped people have been isolated
they've been pushed at home they've had
expectations that have fallen away like
I remember a year ago a lot of people
are like all right we got vaccines now
it's a new year it's going to be a brand
new thing you know 2021 now this year
you talk a lot of people I don't even
have any goals or anything because
they've gone to learned helplessness
because they've been disappointed so
many times they start thinking the
problem's forever no problems forever no
war is forever no pandemic is forever
your mind is weak now and it's gotten a
weak habits and you're in a lowered
state so you start to believe that and
so it's like you got to change people's
State first then you got to give them
the story that can help them they need
to give them the strategies that work in
there even if you don't give them a
strategy they'll figure out their own
strategy you're a perfect example of
that right you've figured it out because
you got yourself to the point where it's
like I've got to turn this around and
then you have something that you can
give and that expands your life as
you've experienced you my rule two is
treat yourself as if you're someone
responsible for helping and it's sort of
predicated on the idea that regardless
of your inadequacies and your
malevolence which you know I'm sure you
have many inadequacies and no shortage
of malevolence just like everyone else
regardless of that you have a moral
obligation so that would be a
responsibility to assume that despite
all evidence that there's actually
something of intrinsic worth about you
and that as a consequence your duty
bound to treat yourself like that is
true
and then it turns out that if you do
that
well then your life gets better
and and I don't mean happier exactly
although I would say it gets happier I
mean it gets richer and more meaningful
and deeper and and more worthwhile and
and you become more educated and you
become wiser and and and you treat
yourself with more respect and you're a
better model for other people and you're
a better father or a better sister or a
better mother whatever it happens to be
it's and you're less ridden by that
guilt that's that gnaws at you and shame
that's there otherwise saying you're not
what you could be you're not what you
could be and that's a hell of a voice to
get rid of and it's certainly not one
that's easy to ignore so that's a pretty
good
that that idea that there's something
Divine let's say that resides within you
of ultimate worth
um
even as a philosophical statement or a
psychological statement rather than a
metaphysical statement it seems to be a
precondition for establishing properly
harmonious relationships with yourself
and that's that's man that's worth
thinking about a lot you know that you
have to because you think you couldn't
think that in some sense you just own
yourself you know because people do kind
of make that claim especially when
they're trying to justify for example
their right to Suicide that you know
it's it's your life it's your body your
yours to do what you will with and if
that was true well then it would seem to
me that life would be a lot more
straightforward because you would just
tell yourself things that you would
instantly obey and believe so first of
all you'd tell yourself all the things
that you were going to do and then you
just run off and do them which you don't
obviously because it's much more
difficult at that and then you'd also
say well enough of the guilt and the
shame and the negative emotion and the
disillusionment and the vengefulness and
all those things that make life hard
especially the self-recrimination it's
like what the hell do we need that for
and if we're our masters of Our Own
Destiny and owners of our own fate then
why can't we just command to ourselves
that that be dispensed with and like
that doesn't work I've never seen
anybody able to do that so I mean you
can fool yourself for very brief periods
of time into thinking that that might
work but
but it doesn't work and and that's
strange and this is one of the reasons I
love the psychoanalysts say because they
were really the people apart from the
religious types who figured out that
whatever you are
you're not a unitary Spirit that's under
your own dominion you know you're
something like a loose Unity of a
multiplicity of spirits many of which
are doing their own thing which you're
striving to bring into some form of
unity but even that Unity isn't
something that's under your control in
any real sense it's it's a Unity that
has its own nature that you have to
exist in relationship to and I would
also say that that's one of the things
that keeps people people's feet firmly
on the ground because otherwise you it's
easy to become egotistical and
narcissistic you know if you if you
think that you're the center of your own
being you know in some fundamental sense
then you're only what you're only
beholden to yourself you're sort of a
self-created creature perhaps you could
think about it that way but it doesn't
work like that it's like the ideal that
constitutes the unity that you might
become then sort of manifests itself is
something that you could strive toward
but aren't and it it also serves as a
judge it's the thing that keeps you up
at night saying you know there's some
things you're just not attending to and
you should get at it because life is
short and there's no shortage of trouble
that you might end up in and a wise
person would attend to the dictates of
his conscience and and lay out his
actions in the world according to what
he knows to be true and correct and
that is how people think and it isn't
obvious that we why we think that way
that this is part of the reason that it
seems to me so obvious that we have a
religious Instinct because I can't think
of what else you would possibly call
that other than a religious Instinct the
biggest difference between you and the
people who you look up to are that they
started
and you're still thinking about it it's
one of the most frustrating things
in helping entrepreneurs
that I deal with on a day-to-day basis
is that seeing so much potential in
people seeing so much heart and love and
care is like you you could be serving so
much and helping so much and having such
a big impact
and and we're stuck
we're stuck
and this was me too I was stuck it took
me forever to get started and I thought
I had to have the the perfect cameraman
my first video if you go back and watch
it on my channel I had my friend come
and film it and record it for me because
I was worried about it not being perfect
enough that I didn't know the gear and
didn't know the microphone and the
lighting and the setup and I I memorized
the script because I didn't want to say
the wrong words I had to be perfect
most of my early videos were were still
mostly voice over because I could write
a script and have it perfect and just
have b-roll and it wouldn't be me on
camera afraid of making a mistake and
saying the wrong things and messing up
and that's one of the main reasons why
it took me so long to grow you know if
you look at my journey of
making what for five years seven
thousand subscribers something like that
it was I was stuck I was I was
I was too afraid to do the next thing I
was too afraid to get in the race I was
making content at least I was one decent
thing for whatever reason I stay
consistent on on doing stuff but I was
afraid to take the next step the big
step to go off and do it and
a lot of you are already way better than
than I was when I started
and when I'm on interviews and I'm I'm
doing events and presentations and I see
the audience and I see who's there and I
see the skill and the and the hearts
just the this is the thing that kills me
the most it's like the hearts like you
want you've got such a good heart you
want to do so much
and then there's just no action there's
no momentum because of the fear
if you could make one change
this year that would really move the
needle it would be to stop judging
yourself for the content that you're
making or the product you're putting out
of the service and just expect it to
suck and keep going
so when people ask me should I should I
do this business or this business should
I do that business or this one's like
well I don't know you know like at the
end of the day it's gonna be what you
love doing all of them could work
every business model can work and has
worked it's what's going to be the right
one for you and you won't know until
you get out there and start doing it
right it's like how do you know what
your favorite food is until you get out
there and do it how do you know if you
like coffee or not you know you have to
go off and you take a sip and then you
find out you can't think your way
through this so you can't think your way
you can have some planning but the
planning won't save you at the end of
the day you have to go off and just do
something about it and in the doing
you'll figure out
what makes you come alive and keep going
so
let's make it practical like let's give
you some steps for how to actually get
in the race and start taking some action
step one
understand
or at least tell yourself that great
ideas flow through you
great ideas flow through you that
because you came up with the idea that
it's a good idea stop judging and stop
telling yourself you suck stop telling
yourself someone like you can't do it
like great ideas flow through you this
is a good idea you need to go do
something about it right even just
telling yourself that shortcuts the fear
because all of the reasons in your head
for why you can't do it is really just
fear if you're thinking about making
content and you're worried about the
microphone and the camera and the gear
and all that that's just fear talking
it's just you're afraid that it won't be
good and so you're trying to cover your
bases and we come up with all these
logical reasons why we can't do it but
really just fear talking so cut through
the fear by telling yourself that great
ideas flow through you
that you don't want to be sitting here
three years later still stuck in the
same spot
right what's the difference well how
much action you took over those three
years and most of us are are stuck in an
action because we're Paralyzed by fear
and we've come up with rational reasons
why we can't do the thing so one great
ideas flow through you trust them and do
something about them two apply what I
call the two percent difference and so
most of the time what's the first thing
we do when we come with an idea when you
come up with an idea you think it's a
great idea you're going to start a
channel you're going to write a book
you're going to create this product
Service Company whatever you come up
with a great idea
the first thing we do is usually
planning right plan plan I need to plan
here's what my perfect world looks like
I'm going to plan all the way out and
what ends up happening is you spend your
best energy planning the first step in
my opinion should not be planning the
first step should be some kind of
imperfect action because what ends up
happening is you get all this energy and
motivation and you feel like you're
unstoppable and you can do it this is
such a good idea
and then you start spending your time
planning and researching what is up
happening is you wake up the next day
and the next day and your energy and
your belief starts to drop it's like oh
what was I thinking I can't do that who
am I to do that the doubts and
insecurities and the fears all start to
pop in and so you you stop
and nothing ends up happening besides a
list of ideas and you're planning and
research but that doesn't that doesn't
get you paid that doesn't get the
service out there doesn't actually help
anybody and so
planning is important it just shouldn't
be the first step the first step should
be some kind of imperfect action just
start doing something anything you you
want to make a YouTube channel great
pull out your phone and make a video
what do you see in the video it doesn't
matter just speak from the heart like
hey I want to start a YouTube channel
I've been thinking about doing this for
a bunch of years and I've always been
too afraid and now I've decided that I'm
going to go off and do it and I don't
know what I'm going to talk about I'm
just going to do my best
and hopefully you'll support me alright
see you soon post there's your video was
it great no but it's everything because
you you started doing something you
think about a fitness plan that people
are going on
what are people normally do on a fitness
plan well you you're researching all do
I do CrossFit do I do weights do I do
cardio do I do Zumba do I do salsa
dancing and you're so caught up we all
get this we all get so caught up in what
the perfect plan is that we never
actually do anything where the the best
thing you can do is go and do 10
push-ups right now or five or two
however many you can do are those two
push-ups gonna make any difference
for the long-term health no I mean no
you're not building muscle from two
push-ups obviously but the moment the
act of momentum is the thing that
matters because in doing the two
push-ups maybe tomorrow you do four the
next day you do six and actually you do
eight and you're starting to build the
habit of somebody who does push-ups that
then can lead you to do more research to
find out oh I was doing the push-ups all
wrong
here's a better way to do it or I should
be doing this instead you'll learn as
you go and the research in the plan is
important it just can't be the first
step so step one again is expect that
great ideas flow through you that that
idea that came to you is good is worthy
you should do it you should at least try
it set number two is two percent
difference what that means is
don't plan to get the hundred percent
for a focus on the first two percent
most of us will plan to figure out what
the 100 looks like you won't know what's
the first two percent you can take
action on right now and just go do it
and then step three is just expect a
suck at the beginning
we expect we don't expect to be great at
the start but we expect to be good we
expect to be at least average at the
start of whatever we do we never think
it's going to be easy I mean some people
do I guess but for the most part you
don't think whatever you're getting into
is going to be easy but you don't expect
it to be as hard as it is and you don't
expect to be as bad as you are at the
thing and it doesn't mean that you're
bad as a human it just means that you're
bad at the skill
and so how do you get skills well by by
practicing by doing it by training right
and so you're going to be way worse
than you thought you would be at the
beginning that's okay you just don't
have the skill yet so I go into any new
thing expecting to suck just completely
expect to suck expected to be a total
failure and if it's not then great and
every day you get up and you do it again
you'll be a little bit better and you'll
suck a little bit less because you're
developing the skills you can get really
really good at something if you have
passion energy and your pouring time
into actually improving at it where most
people
will just make one thing
see how much it sucks and then never go
back to it so just expect it to be
terrible at the beginning
don't worry so much about how much of a
failure that first one was and then you
keep going keep you make another one
tomorrow and another one tomorrow
another tomorrow and you will get better
if you follow that process this is this
is how you actually start becoming the
person who you want to be you start
getting the results and the impact that
you want to have
you've got the heart and the talent and
and the the abilities and the care
the difference is just there's no
momentum where there's not enough
momentum for what you're capable of and
so if you follow those three steps
right great ideas flow through you
believe it follow the two percent
difference instead of planning research
and do something you need action and
then three expect to suck and keep going
you get that momentum you need start
changing your life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for the
seven life lessons I wish I knew earlier
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there money can't buy
happiness I'm sure you've heard that a
thousand times but I want to tell you
why it can't buy you happiness but why
people keep chasing money because people
are always going to chase money and the
reason people are going to chase money
is because it is extraordinarily